How many solutions does the following system of linear equations have?
Here is what this system is about. There are several ways to decide.
One is graphic. We have to decide if they are
of the same rights and accordingly have an infinite number of decisions,
or are parallel, i.e., will never cross, and then there is no solution,
or intersect at one point and then we will have one solution.
But let's approach algebraically. Let's try to solve it
system and see what we will get.
The first equation will leave it unchanged 5x-9u = 16. Want
to shorten members with x, so I will multiply the second equation
by minus one and so -5x and 5x will be destroyed each other.
I multiply the second equation by minus one
and the result is -5x + 9u = -36
Now I will gather the left side of the equation with the right,
to get a new equation.
5x - 5x
is equal to zero.
-9u + 9u will also be zero,
which makes 0 on the left side,
but on the right
we have 16 - 36 = -20
And now I find myself with a strange equation,
according to which 0 equals -20
It is logical to think that this can not be true.
But the way we have to think in this case is
"Are there values ​​for x and y where 0 is equal to -20?"
No, 0 will never be -20. Does not matter
what are the x and y values. There is no 0 equal to -20.
In fact, x and y disappeared from this equation.
There is no way this is true.
So I will write "No solutions."
If you draw these lines, you will notice that they are parallel,
therefore they have the same slope at different intersections with y.
And that's why we have no solution - they do not intersect.
Let's solve another problem. It is very funny.
How many solutions does the following system of linear equations have?
I will leave the first equation unchanged: -6x + 4y equals 2.
And the second one? See if I can cut the member with x.
If I multiply it by 2, I will get + 6x.
I will multiply this whole equation, both sides, by 2.
I will get: 6x (3x by 2 is 6x) -2y by 2 is -4y
and this will be -2. Now let's do the following.
Let's collect the things on the left and the things on the right.
So -6x + 6x will be equal to 0.
4y - 4y is 0. On the left side we have 0.
On the right side we have 2 + minus 2, also equals 0.
It's a bit different and yet it looks weird 0 = 0.
Last time, we had 0 equals -20.
Now we have 0 = 0. Let's think - equality even though x and y are gone
already in the equation ...
Then which pair of values ​​for y and y will give
true equality 0 = 0? Does not matter,
this will be true for any pair of values ​​of x and y.
In fact, x and y are no longer involved in the equation.
0 will always be equal to 0,
here we can have countless solutions.
And because they are the same lines - they just look different
algebraically, but if you plot one of them on a scale ...
If you multiply both sides of the second equation by -2,
you will get the first equation.
Yes, they represent the same rights.
We have countless solutions.
When trying to find the solution of the following system
of linear equations, Yvonne takes a number of faithful steps,
which lead to equation -5 is equal to 20.
How many solutions does the linear equation system have?
I do not even have to look at the system.
Because she has received something that can not be true: -5 never
will not be equal to 20, and that shows us that she has no solution.
And if you try to draw the graphics, you'll see
that they are parallel.
That's why they have no solution. They never cross.
There is no pair of values ​​for x and y that satisfies both conditions.
Let's decide a few more.
When trying to find a solution
of the following system of linear equations, Albus performs several
the correct steps that lead to the equation 5y equals -5.
How many solutions does this system have of linear equations?
5y equals -5.
We can divide both sides to 5 and get y = -1.
And if we substitute in y = -1 in the first equation,
if y is equal to -1, the result is +2.
You can draw 2 on both sides and get 5x = 4.
Or you will get what x is equal to 4/5.
Or, if you put -1 here, you will get 5x - 3 = 1.
You can add 3 on both sides and you will get 5x = 4.
x is equal to 4/5.
So we have only one solution. We obtain x is equal to 4/5,
y is equal to -1.
Let's decide one more.
By trying to solve the following system of linear equations, Leaven
performs several correct steps that lead to 0 = 0.
I do not even have to look at that.
Zero zero is always true,
it will have countless decisions.